>> I think India does have the capacity to
become a superpower.
First of all, it is by far the largest country
within its own region.
It has the capacity that sort of to play a
dominant regional role and
having a regional base from which to be a
global power is vital.
China has the because within East Asia, the
United States has a base
within its hemisphere, and traditionally Britain
and France had bases
within their hemispheres.
So this is very important.
Secondly, its size and its resources, its
human resources, also its
material resources, give it the capacity to
really take advantage of a
market power.
Part of what makes America a superpower is
that people want access to
its market.
People want our influence by its level of
worth.
And over time by unlocking the potential of
its people, India can
achieve that kind of economic superpower base
without which it's very
hard to be a world power.
Ultimately, you've got to make a choice to
invest in defense to be a
superpower.
And I know the Indian government is making
several steps in this
direction.
But over time, that's something that has to
be sustained in order that
for a superpower status United States to be
retained.
To create and antibodies and reactions from
your neighbors which carry
a price and Indian government have to make
its choice.
The final point I think would be about a system
of government.
To be a superpower, you need to have a strong
capacity to get power
from a strong, central political base.
The United States, although like India federally
very split, has been
able to centralize power with its foreign
policy issues around the
President.
So the Congress is very powerful but it is
more powerful on domestic
issues than it is on foreign issues.
That's a big question is whether India will
develop a similar type of
political structure with a center and really
play a active role in
foreign policy, while probably still being
very federal and divided in
some cases in its domestic policy.